welcome everybody to part four of our
Google cloud tutorial series in this
video what we're doing is covering a new
API and that is going to be the natural
language API so what we need to do first
is since it's a new API we need to
enable that API to use it so we can type
language Google Cloud natural language
API and that's actually already enabled
so I don't need to do anything but if
yours is not enabled to go ahead and hit
enable and you're ready to go once
you've done that that's all we need to
do in that console so now what I'm going
to do is go ahead and change directory
back one and I'm gonna go ahead and make
Durr NAT Lange's ample CD Nataly example
and then now I'm going to nano I guess
NAT Lang example not pi okay
so the first thing I want to go ahead
and do is we're going to from Google dot
plow we're going to import language and
then just like before if you want you
could say you know client equals
language dot client that looks very
similar to the vision API now let's go
ahead make a function out of this so
we're gonna define language analysis and
language analysis we'll just take some
degree of text it's really open to and
the first thing we're gonna do is we're
going to say basically our text document
so we're gonna say document equals
client document underscore Brown
underscored text or make sure it doesn't
run over face and this takes one
parameter and that is the text now we're
gonna say sense underscore analysis for
sentiment analysis is going to be equal
or something fixes equal to document dot
analyze underscore sentiment and then
just to show you what your options are
I'm just going to do a guess in this
case we'll actually print it so it's do
print der sense analysis and then what
we're gonna say is sentiment equals
sense analysis sentiment so I'm just
gonna save us time that's a one of the
methods now what we're gonna do next is
we're gonna say int for entity analysis
equals documents 100 document channel
analyze entities and then finally an
Entenmann's
entities equals int analysis entities
and then we'll just return sentiments
and entities so basically the language
API we can even like we can look more
into it too so like let's see if I can
find documentation view the
documentation let's see if we can find
maybe concepts yes so this kind of tells
you what all your options are so you've
got sentiment analysis entity analysis
and syntactic analysis so analyze syntax
would be your other option I'm not going
to do this in tactic analysis they used
they had some pictures before but I'm
not seeing the beautiful pictures let's
go to a product overview see if this has
the pretty pictures I'm not seeing the
pretty pictures maybe how to you guys
I don't know anyway the things that are
available to us are SEM analysis entity
D analysis and that syntactic analysis
and basically the two that we're going
to use here are sound analysis and
entity analysis in sentiment analysis
will give us two things it gives us
sentiment and then salience was it or
magnitude I can't remember what it is
it's uh I think its magnitude and then
entities will have salience so sentiment
will have the sentiment score which is
negative 1 to positive 1 and then
magnitude which is unbounded and just 0
to infinity so it's just how important
is the sentiment you know to overall and
then with entities you've got again the
same thing it's kind of like what's the
entity and then the salience is like
what is that in and he's importance
basically and that's that so let's just
look at a few examples so cool so that's
our language analysis so now what we're
gonna say is let's come up with some
example text so example underscore text
equals is it not obvious that Python is
the best programming language of them ok
that's our example text and then what
we're gonna say is let's go ahead and
say sentiment and titties equals
language analysis example text and then
let's go ahead and print we can do
sentiment that score for the actual
sentiment itself and then we can do
sentiment magnitude and then so that's
just so sentiment is gonna be on the
entire document right so whatever text
you pass through it's just gonna return
the sentiment so if you wanted it to get
sentiment per sentence or something like
that you you would have to split the
sentences yourself now what we're going
to do is the entities that's going to be
something to iterate over you're gonna
have multiple entities so for E and
jeez we're going to print this has
you've got Nate you got quite a few
things but we're gonna do name a dot
entity type so the name is just what is
the entity so basically from the tax
base so it's gonna be the text name
entity type is gonna be like what's the
classification of this entity metadata
which is pretty cool a dot metadata this
will be again if there is information on
this entity it'll return metadata to you
and then e dot salience basically the
importance all right so let's go ahead
and save that yes let's do that lane net
I'm always forgetting Python Natalie an
example that by okay so on the first one
basically here's our sentiment it's
slightly positive and the magnitude is
also just kind of it and and I'm not
really sure I'd agree with that return
okay next we have basically the entities
so it's got Python other which is the
type this is your metadata so this gives
you the met which is actually pretty
cool because it actually detects that
this is the Python programming language
because I think we actually used
programming language in the actual text
but it so it realized oh this is not
Python the the snake this is actually
Python the programming language which is
pretty nifty and it gives you the
Wikipedia page and then it tells you the
salience the importance well obviously
it's very important here and then here
you've got programming language which
again is just other no metadata on this
one and then the salience is just really
not important we're clearly talking
about Python here so yeah that's pretty
pretty darn cool so now let's let's work
with like maybe a little bit more text
so I'm going to come over here and let's
go ahead and search for Python and let's
go to that Wikipedia page now let's just
take like these three paragraphs here
and let's just copy come back to the
terminal edit this and now the example
text
I'm just going to delete it all I'm
gonna say example text equals triple
quote right click triple quote beautiful
save that let's run that again and then
now what you can see is from all that
text and in fact let me just make some
space so I know I'm not running into the
other one there we go so right out of
the gate we've got sentiment which is
more positive than my sentiment saying
the Python is the best language but all
right
maybe that Python it recognizes this is
an organization first you've got Guido
van Rossum being noticed noted as a
person who also has his own Wikipedia
URL pretty cool
you've got C Python which also has its
own Wikipedia so on it recognizes Java
C++ all these other things anyway a lot
of information your Python Software
Foundation too got that as an
organization and then you get all like
the importance so like for example this
one should be pretty darn important
right it's it's got probably the most
important so for all these others and if
I was to just take a quick guess here it
looks like these are sorted for you in
the order of that salience so yeah the
most important thing that it thinks is
at the top and then as you get down to
the bottom you get to the lesser
important things there's another kind of
interesting that Python Software
foundations at the bottom of court in
Styles just don't matter interesting
okay so that's the natural language API
example I'm really there's not too much
for me more to talk about here but this
is actually really impressive so if
you're running impressed by the the
vision API in the natural language API
up to this point I don't have to tell
you but this is actually pretty cool
stuff there's so much that's going into
this that's detecting the entities if
you've ever worked with like NL TK for
example with named entity recognition
it's really difficult like it'll screw
up like with Python Software Foundation
it'll like detect Python software or
foundation or just Python as also the
organization
like you're not gonna get metadata
that's for sure um it's just not gonna
be this good and it's not gonna detect
salience you're gonna have to figure
that one out on your own and then the
other thing with like the sentiment
sentiments really challenging and the
same thing with also magnitude like
these are really challenging things and
for this to just boom it's just if
you're not impressed it's probably
because it's so simple like the API just
makes it so frickin simple and the other
thing too is like for example I just
type of language let's go to the
language API no oh here we're already
there I just want to go to the prices
let's see if I can find prices here we
go
so if you're only I don't I guess units
I'm not sure what units is is that like
text that you sent through because I
would think text that he sent through
for sentiment sure I guess that's maybe
fair but for entity recognition it
should depend on what the size is but
anyway feature and then I don't know if
this is like per unit a dollar pretty I
don't really know I honestly don't know
like if this is I'm assuming this price
is how much you would pay for like the
first million units you just pay another
dollar I'm not positive on that I'm not
really sure I want to test it but if
that's the truth like if you're only
paying a dollar what is this let's see
limit 420 trying to see if you pay per
unit because if you pay per unit and a
unit was let's say just each thing you
submitted that would be an asinine cost
but I think it's actually yeah I don't
know because this gets cheaper so
doesn't make any sense so it has to be
per unit but the first 5,000 units are
totally free and then is this per unit I
don't know someone comment below if you
know Oh price per thousand units okay so
anyways a dollar per day
units wow that could get expensive quick
if you're in a million units but even
even for something like like syntax comm
which is sentiment analysis and
currently I do that all on my own
you know that's I don't try to think of
how many updates a day that probably
runs through I'm trying to see all let's
do seven days probably like a million
updates or something or something close
to that for like an entire article
so you'd be probably in this range and a
thousand I don't know it's probably
pretty expensive but at the same time I
don't know because you also have to
think about how much you know you cuz
you either have to process this on your
own or on your server and in fact let me
just pause this real quick I want to do
some math room real fast okay yeah so
I'm back now so like for example if you
wanted to run like the full Twitter fire
hose or something get sentiment on each
of those it looks like that would cost
you probably about $2,000 a month just
running some quick numbers there so
that's pretty high actually for that one
but I'm gonna find let me get one of the
other ones since I was I'm I think let's
talk about the vision I think the vision
when I was pretty impressed with as far
as cost was concerned at least you can
get up to five K units for free that's
pretty cheap let's go to any
documentation where was the pricing I
forget how I even got to pricing on the
other one pricing there's 10 loaded yet
yes so like this one is interesting
prices per thousand units so like for
label detection and OCR stuff and all
that like for on image data like these
prices are really good that's I'm kind
of surprised that it would take an image
data like image data and natural
language data are priced so similarly
like the process at least from what I've
done maybe I'm doing it wrong but the
process an image and a train image
classifiers is totally different than
doing like a text text analysis like
text analysis is not anywhere near what
image analysis costs but anyway so the
image stuff is really good but yeah for
the for the text analysis I guess I just
I had looked at prices already for the
vision API but I hadn't seen it for the
text analysis so the text analysis is
pretty darn impressive but if you're
trying to do big volume and you're gonna
pay that might they should work on their
pricing if you ask me I know they're
asking me anyway
that's it on natural language if you
have any questions comments concerns
feel free to leave them them below
otherwise we're gonna be moving on to
yet another API probably the last ones
I'll probably release in this this one
but that's gonna be the translation API
which is another one that's like super
quick super easy super powerful I'm not
positive on the pricing I'll look at the
pricing but I think it's I wonder if
that one since I've since I'm already
here let's let's look at it you can feel
free to close out the window if you
don't if you don't care about this I'm
not gonna say anything more important at
this point
oops I hit the wrong button API Docs if
you want to hear my opinion on Google's
pricing models yeah it's kind of weird
twenty dollars per se like this is on a
per character basis why is the
translation API on a per character basis
but the sentiment API is not late right
it should be on a character basis
especially because so many people are
trying to do sentiment analysis on like
tweets and stuff like that so but I mean
I guess if you were doing like document
sentiment so I guess the sentiment
analysis or like the natural language
API makes a lot of sense
if you're doing it on large documents
like entire articles or even more so
like on
yeah like journalists types of things
like very long things like New York
Times posts days and days or like medium
articles yeah so and then this one's on
a per character I their natural language
API should be on a per character basis
anyway 20 dollars per million characters
which that seems pretty fair you know
for a translation API I think that's
okay they don't have a free tier though
that's kind of a bummer price per
character sent to the API includes white
includes whitespace characters empty
queries charge for a character charges
per care on a per character basis even
if the character is multiple bytes
pro-rata proportional and incremental
cool anyway yeah so that makes sense I'm
not quite sure
like I said Google if you're listening
why is the natural language API not on a
per character basis okay anyway uh
that's it like I said nothing important
see in the next video